now for the first time pensioners are
earning more than their working age
equivalent a study by the resolution
foundation says pensioner incomes have
grown by more than thirty percent since
2001 while the combination of slow wage
growth and rising house prices has left
the younger generations worse off
joining me to dig into the detail is
Connor darcia policy analyst at the
resolution foundation Connor thanks for
joining us here and it's perhaps that
finding about how pensioners are now
doing better with their incomes than
working-age people which I think might
might be striking people we can put a
chant up I think just showing that how
that's happened over the course of the
last few years how there has been that
overtaking and you can see here
pensioners the red line there overtaking
working age families for the first time
this is this a big moment we're talking
about here I think I think it is I mean
as you can see that gap has really
narrowed over the last few years but I
think the same time this shouldn't mean
that this means you know all pensioners
are doing fantastically or all of their
incomes of reason you know this kind of
overall group has done really well but
individual pensioners won't have done as
well they'll seen you know gains but not
as quickly as this I think some of that
is because a lot of the driver of this
increase is the slightly younger
pensioners who recently retired who you
know they have baby boomers yeah exactly
they're the key folks I've done this
this this for real kind of key reasons
why they've done better and why that
charts moving in that direction firstly
they're more likely to retire with quite
generous private pensions or
occupational pensions there's home
ownership you know Homer shipped rates
are much higher than in previous
generations especially for you know baby
boomers we see more and more working and
continuing working and you know maybe
just a few hours or staying on full-time
has been a really big factor and then
benefits have gotten gradually more
generous for older people's a few trains
contributing to that but a lot of people
have a particularly pensions would look
at this and they'd say okay well that's
that's one thing but we've had many
years where pensioners have suffered you
know a lot of talking about pension of
poverty things like the winter fuel
allowance were supposed to ameliorate
that you know this is just a recent
thing they would say and it is tough for
many pensioners and has been in some
time absolutely I mean we're not taking
away from you the existence of pension
poverty I think the overall story here
is a really positive one it's it's great
that we've seen more and more pain
is being better off I think it's just
that we need to make sure that
working-age people the kind of some of
the cuts that they're facing in there in
work benefits and other things like you
know can't they get on the housing
ladder I think those are some of the
other challenges that this kind of
highlights then you mentioned the
housing ladder I've got one other chart
which is also formula formula report one
we've adapted showing different
generations and how many of them are
able to get on the housing ladder that
the big blue chunk that we see in each
of those lines shows you who is a
homeowner and you can see baby boomers
lots of them about seventy percent
Generation X so that's the next one up
up to at the end of the 70s about fifty
percent but Millennials really
struggling to get on the housing ladder
there yeah I think yeah so there's a
short-term issue of how much this costs
and you're living in private rented
accommodation is just more expensive in
general than having a mortgage but I
think you also need to consider the the
longer term implications of this because
for you know for that for that baby
boomer generation they're not paying
very much for their housing in their
retirement because it's barely paid off
their mortgage whereas for the
Millennials if they haven't managed to
buy their own home or completely pay off
their mortgage by the time they're
hitting 60 and 70 that's another extra
cost and a pressure on their living
standards then and just very quickly if
you had to give to kind of one policy
which would help to sort that out what
would it be I mean house buildings
definitely one really important one as
well as looking at you know in work
benefits in the support that goes to
working-age people today I think is a
real key one